près le
[Musique]
dé tu avancer dessus franc ou tu on y va
ouais d'accord
est un peu à droite de l'image peut-être
c'est beau ça regarde le mec le mec la
balle déchiré bon de toute façon les de
bateaux derrière
de
bate c'est joli
ça ça tient en di ça ça tient en lumière
c'est beau hein c'est beau ça beau hein
je suis en train de monter l'ambiance tu
vois
regarde joli
çaarde l'ombre du bateau aussi tu
descends un peu
voilà
un c'est joli
ça
la la laisse dans la brillance reste
dans la
brillance j'ouvre la porte doucement par
soleil ch coupe c'est joli çau un peu
plus tu vas le souffler tu vas le
souffler je vois le ventre déjà qui
arrive sur lui il va s'arrêter à cause
de nous mais non je suis en train de
rec
pourquoi les rayons de dans
l'eau pass dans la brillance non c'est
beau c'est beau la
[Musique]
voile un peu près comme ça reste comme
ça reste comme ça laisse
s laiss pass la brillance vachement la
brillance dans la voile à peu près c'est
super beau super
beau
voilà c'est beau ça j'arrive j'arrive
[Musique]
attends
un pe plus bas tu CIS pas que plus
jolisendsiss fa je laiss d'abord je je
pose c'est vraiment pas
pourment le SO
se il passère un nuage ou ouis plus de
soleil
[Musique]
voilà
allez C on y
[Musique]
retourne
ah c'est joli ça le soleil r un peu
serré mon petit lapin là
ok attends trop serr là
en entier c'est joli je trouve
he je
faire peu truc
autour
[Musique]
trop j'ai
l'impression voilà c'est plus joli quand
même comme ça regarde c'est vachement
plus beau comme ça regarde comme c'est
beau ça ah ouais ouais c'est beau c'est
magnifique ça bien qu on voit me un
petit peu c'est bon il reste comme ça
parce que c'est beau ça on se demande ce
que
[Musique]
c'est regarde
regarde est loin ant je demandais
juste REM dans la brillance un
peu Arve dans la
brillance beau l'au qui qui qui regarde
la voile va aller dedans c'est
magnifique
ça
regarde fais un point dans la dans la
voile dans la voile la brillance à
travers la voile tu vois regarde ça pe
donner làdans voilà comme ça joli
regarde le plan la voile avec le mec
c'est super beau ça tu vois voilà
regarde c'est beau ça tu vois la
brillance qui passe à travers la voile
oh là là c'est super beau ça regarde
regarde regardee il va vraiment falloir
changer de
cassette fin la cassette comme ça c'est
pas grave fin là bah non si on va faire
comme le toi c'est ouais c'est pas grave
la cassette on sera plus là mon pote
plus fini on va le refaire quand même tu
vois 10 secondes de Cu c'est
pas dans la
voile
dans la voile avec le mec c'est
magnifique ça
[Musique]
Sublim
allez
change c'est vachement beau
ça
écoute surain